Hello america as the original superhero i assure
you that you are in safe hands with us i'm soldier
boy and i approve this message god bless you
soldier boy now look there's been a little drama
around vought of lake but i want to reassure you
here and now superheroes are still the good guys
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new video for the boys season three first
look they just dropped jensen ackles first look
at soldier boy and i'll explain what's going on
with his character he's obviously going to be like
the new really big character they're introducing
like stormfront was the brand new character during
season two so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos the
show runner has already revealed some of what's
going on with the episodes right now like he's
been posting a lot of his own reactions in the
edit bay because they've been filming for a
while now and jensen ackles has been on set
posting a bunch of behind the scenes like you can
see him trying to get ripped like slowly working
out obviously they use a lot of muscle suits and
there's a lot of padding and in his full-blown
costume here you can see they're going for a
very captain america vibe because soldier boy is
basically the boy's version of marvel's captain
america or the avengers captain america however
you want to think about him even though usually
when you think of the boys you think mostly of dc
comics because the seven is sort of their version
of the justice league but the boyz is satire and
parody of a lot of marvel characters as well
with a lot of their other teams particularly the
payback team which is a big reference to marvel's
avengers like the revengers so i will explain some
of the changes that they're making to soldier boy
in the payback team during the boys season 3 from
the comics because it will be a slightly different
version if you have no idea what's going on jensen
ackles just finished supernatural they just ended
that show and his first big role after that is the
boys season 3 because the showrunner of the boys
tv series eric kripke was also one of the creators
on supernatural so they've already been a bunch of
supernatural actors that have shown up on the boys
before like bobby singer was a big character
and i think his character's name was also the
same as his character's name on supernatural and
they've been talking about bringing jeffrey dean
morgan on the tv show as a new character during a
future season as well i don't know if jeffrey dean
morgan is going to make it into season three but
maybe season four so obviously the intro there is
jensen ackles doing his best impression of captain
america soldier boy like he's portrayed by vought
is this very goody two-shoes captain america
type character big boy scout but in the comics
soldier boy is actually two different characters
so originally there was a soldier boy that had the
traditional captain america origin story from the
marvel universe so in the world of the boys back
during world war ii superheroes vought compound
be that all came out of world war ii in vogelbaum
who started as a nazi scientist but then came to
america during operation paperclip and started
vaude american where they started experimenting
on americans creating superheroes the way that
you see them in modern day but during world war
ii the americans also tried to develop their own
super soldier serum their own version of compound
v and that was soldier boy he was their prototype
but as is the case with a lot of the modern
day superheroes he had no idea how to use his
superpowers he was a terrible superhero he got
his whole squad killed the mallory character in
the comics also wound up killing him as revenge
for getting his squad killed so the original
version of soldier boy in the comics dies back
during world war ii then in present day there's
a really awkward bumbling version of soldier boy
who's this big suck-up wants to be on the seven
does whatever homelander tells him to do they have
this really really messed up relationship that the
schoner already said they're not going to be doing
on the tv show so like they're doing the herogasm
you're not going to see that quote-unquote special
scene between the modern soldier boy and homeland
like no we're not going to do that let's just say
if you thought that homelander did some messed up
sex stuff during season 2 it gets even crazier
during the herogasm is like the worst nightmare
version of spring break with superheroes but the
modern day version of the character also winds up
leading the payback team which winds up being vots
sort of b team to the seven the seven is still
like their biggest team their biggest money earner
for all this merchandise this big financial empire
that they're trying to use these superheroes to
create remember the whole twist behind vought
creating superheroes is really just to create
these financial empires so payback their version
of marvel's avengers is like the b team to the
seven they're sort of like the feeder team like
if someone dies on the seven usually someone from
payback gets bumped up but here's what they're
doing on the tv show with jensen echo's character
what they're doing is they're sort of combining
both the old version and the present-day version
of soldier boy and it's just going to be one
character he'll start out as the original version
created during world war ii in just like captain
america in the marvel avengers movies he's going
to survive the present day just like stormfront on
the tv show was created during world war ii and
then just continued to live like she didn't age
she just kept living on until present day changing
her identity but because the secret of superheroes
had been kept up to the events of season two
like the public didn't learn about compound v
till season two most people believe that the
original soldier boy died sometime after world
war two like he grew old and died so they'll have
some backstory for how the new version of soldier
boy shows up but it's still the same version it'll
be another lie that vap perpetrates the same way
that they sort of upheld stormfront's lie when
giancarlo esposito's character knew exactly what
was going on with her the whole time they said
the reason why they're introducing the soldier
boy character now why he's so important for season
three's storyline is because they want to get into
the origin of superheroes and they're going to
use him to tell that because he's very literally
america's original superhero even though
stormfront is technically the first superhero
because she was the test subject or the first test
subject that survived the treatments just talking
about the costume changes too obviously they
changed it quite a bit from the comic book version
of soldier boy to make it seem even different from
marvel's version of captain america because it
does look a lot more like captain america's colors
in the comics both versions of the character the
one from world war ii and the one in present day
the shield does look a little bit more comic book
accurate but i think the reason why they made this
green was so that marvel doesn't have any cause to
try and sue them like yes we know this is a parody
of captain america but disney please don't come
sue us the way the producers in the cast talk
about his relationship with homelander makes it
sound like it's going to be kind of antagonistic
because homelander is obviously very territorial
and very insecure like he's just thirsty for
everyone's love and attention and he's gone
even more off the rails than he already was as
of the end of season two like just jerking off
on top of the empire state building i believe it
was maybe it was the chrysler building i wasn't
quite sure which building that was either way he's
just doing whatever the hell he feels like that's
this whole thing i can do whatever i want as he
just slowly goes mad so a lot of people when they
heard the jensen knackles was going to be this
big force during season three they're like what's
going to stop homelander from just punching his
fist through his face on the spot like how does
a captain america level person fight a homelander
level person because homelander is still meant to
be the most powerful person on the planet and in
the comics their version of soldier boy is about
as strong as marvel's version of captain america
like chris evans captain america who obviously
could not stand toe-to-toe with thor like he
could probably stand his ground for like five
seconds but then thor would just throw him like a
rag doll across the battlefield like when captain
america was trying to stop thanos during infinity
war like just for a brief second he was able to
give him pause but thanos was so powerful he was
just surprised that was really what stopped him it
wasn't the captain america was strong enough to
stop him so the showrunner said their big trick
with dealing with this power scaling problem that
they have with homelander because homeland is so
powerful he would kill anybody that he wanted to
on the spot the way they said they treat him from
a story perspective is that they deal with him in
a more psychological way like characters attack
him in a more psychological way like he really
doesn't have a kryptonite the way that superman
has a kryptonite unless you want to think of
milk as its kryptonite so the way they talk about
jensen ackle's version of soldier boy on the tv
show it sounds like he's just going to be waging a
psychological war against homelander but i'm sure
that they will actually come to some kind of blows
like there'll be some threat of them actually
going at it at some point but they haven't fully
explained what he's going to be doing in present
day most of what they've been talking about is how
they deal with his origin story back during world
war ii but you can see how them keeping him alive
this whole time since world war ii obviously with
the compound v explainer because it stops you from
aging that's the whole twist with stormfront at
the end of season two the showrunner said this
storm front is coming back so everyone post all
your darth vader jokes like she's basically this
burnt piece of toast but she is still very
much alive this is the way they talked about
it in the writers room is they couldn't imagine a
worse punishment for her someone who grew up with
the ideals that she had looking like this hideous
monster but she will not die unless vought allows
her to die and apparently they are definitely not
going to let that happen anytime soon like even
though they have the teaser at the end of season
two where they have a big press conference where
they blame everything on stormfront she's being
held in a facility and she will answer for her
crimes aya cash is like i hope they bring me back
but the showrunner did say oh no she's coming back
like she is not dead she's still very much alive
she's just kind of like a vegetable right now
so i cannot wait to see what they do with her
during season three is going to be messed up
but not quite as messed up as the herogasm and
it won't be exactly like the comic book herogasm
like they probably won't go full monty with it but
it will be crazy there's obviously so much other
stuff that's happening during season three though
you have all the stuff that's happening with
victoria newman and her new agency this tasked
with regulating superheroes but she herself is
secretly a superhero huey thinking that he left
the boys because he wanted to get away from that
is actually just rushing right into the belly of
the beast and the whole idea that vought is the
only source of compound v and she's a superhero
that means that at some point she would have had
to have gotten it from vought or been associated
with fought so i do like the theory that she is
connected to stan edgar and it's all about his
grand plan for getting vought inside the white
house victoria newman on the show is actually
based on a comic book character called vic
the veep because he was the vice president but he
was also a former ceo of vought before stan edgar
was so the tv show is going to be a little bit
different but because of the easter eggs they're
playing with it just sounds like they're heading
to that white house plot by the end of the series
but i don't know if they're going to get there
by season four season five however long the show
winds up running there's a whole bunch of big
stuff happening this week my full loki episode
one video is going to post on wednesday make sure
you have alerts enabled so you don't miss any of
that there'll be a couple big trailers there's
lots of rumors about a spider-man far from home
trailer sometime soon whatever winds up releasing
of course i'll do videos for everything i'll put a
link for all my videos for the boys episodes down
in the description but click here for my brand new
non-spoilery loki episode 1 review video and click
here for that brand new thor 4 love and thunder
first look teaser thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!